you think don lemon is the only
ridiculous person
uh
sort of out there pretending to be a
journalist well then there's this thing
called npr national public radio and
it's partially at least funded by us the
taxpayers and you would think that if we
the people are funding uh news if we're
funding journalism that it would be
impartial because it's for all of us and
we're all feeding into it
that's not how it works people
npr had a report that basically said
that uh supreme court justice neil
gorsuch who is vaccinated but just chose
not to wear a mask that in essence he's
been in a fight with sonia sotomayor
who's also a supreme court justice
because she wants him to be wearing a
mask she of course is vaccinated well
but she has diabetes so she wants him to
be in a mask because you know whatever
you want someone else to do with their
health and put on their body and
everything else you know it's now up to
you that's more important than what they
want anyway this story went bananas
yesterday like everybody was saying he's
trying to kill her and it's horrible and
everything else but then of course it
basically turned out not to be true so
even the new york times the failing
miserable propaganda outlet all the news
that's fit to make up the new york times
even they had to sort of backtrack from
it we've got some info from the new york
times i don't get to quote them that
often on this show in an unusual joint
statement on wednesday justices sonia
sotomayor and neil gorsuch sought to
rebut reports that justice gorgeous
refusal to wear a mask at a supreme
court at supreme court arguments has
created a tension between them reporting
that justice sotomayor asked justice
gorsuch to wear a mask surprised us the
statement said it is false while we may
sometimes disagree about the law
we are warm colleagues and friends a few
hours later chief justice john roberts
issued his own statement i did not
request justice gorsuch or any other
justice to wear a mask on the bench he
said since the justices returned this
month from their holiday break all of
them started to wear masks in the
courtroom except justice gorsuch
and now what you might find interesting
about this you're not going to believe
this guys this one are you sitting if
you're if you're standing
while you're watching this you need to
sit right now because
cable news the pundits what did they do
with this story well take a look
anti-mask insanity has now reached the
highest court in the land neil gorsuch
is prioritizing his right to be a tool
over protecting sonia sotomayor's life
gorsuch loves coven which makes him the
perfect perfect republican he thinks
very little of coronavirus precautions
gorsuch has the nerve to refuse to wear
a mask indoors while seated next to his
colleague who's vulnerable to possible
death from a highly communicable disease
where's the collegiality where's the
common sense that just seems ridiculous
can you put a mouse on seriously polite
what kind of workplace is this it's not
hard justice gorsuch had to know that
this would become a public controversy
um and so i think he did this as a
branding opportunity what's up with
justice gorsuch if all of the other
including all of the other conservative
members of the court are willing to go
along with this
why not him every other justice is
masking up even clarence thomas who
doesn't seem to care about anybody
but nope
not gorsuch he could not be bothered to
extend a life-saving courtesy to his
co-worker it not only displays a lack of
basic civility as a co-worker but also a
lack of humanity while gorsuch's
behavior here is pretty disgraceful i
guess it shouldn't be that surprising a
prickly justice not exactly beloved even
by his conservative soul mates on the
court confirmation of what we all
already knew whatever you think about
mass gorsuch who sits next to sotomayor
at work just decided to be a dick to a
colleague neil gorsuch's shame on you
shame on you
i mean those are all horrible people
they are propagandists and liars the
story turned out to be false
but it's one of those stories where even
when you start hearing about it i was in
the middle of a lot of stuff yesterday
unpacking and everything else but as i
saw it coming across twitter it was like
this doesn't even ring as true but they
all use it for their political purposes
so i get it joy reid should just be put
in a mental institution in a padded cell
like you really she should be studied
truly
but the rest of these people yes he
really wants to kill her and also if the
vaccines work and he's vaccinated
gorsuch and she's vaccinated sotomayor
and she's wearing a mask why would he
also have to wear a mask and these liars
and that's all that they are it's like
they're in studios not wearing masks
they have co-workers who might have
diabetes who might be fat who might have
a whole bunch of other stuff going on do
you think they care and do you think
they wear masks when they're at
restaurants and breaking all the rules
that they are telling you and of course
to reference the earlier story don lemon
said this is a pandemic of the
unvaccinated right it's unvaccinated
people causing new variants except
they're both vaccinated so they're
sitting next to each other and she's got
a mask and they're both vaccinated so
what really is going on here and just
more than anything else that they would
dare say things like she wants them to
die right that he wants her to die
like do you think that perhaps that's a
bit over the top but these are
ridiculous people who have brainwashed
millions and millions of people
and it's our job to fix this we must fix
it we must save society that's the plan